um so we're all very excited um for the
new downton movie so when did you
realize that the show had become as huge
as it did i think it was uh the first
season had come out in the uk hadn't
come out in the states yet and i was
back in ireland doing a play so i'd
missed all kind of the big you know
everyone talking in the buzz i was on
this on the tube on the underground in
london going back in to meet all the
cast to watch the final episode and i
got on and i noticed the whole carriage
went
and someone very unsubtly went
and everyone's like oh yeah it's the
driver
okay it's kind of weird got off and my
character has a name yeah it's tom tom
branson
i am more than the driver
but it was really bizarre and then i
walked out of the of the tube and was
just walking down the street and about
10 more people were like driver driver
oh my god all i'm missing is the car you
know
that's amazing so what your character
was only supposed to be in a few
episodes three episodes in the first
season they loved you that much well i
don't know but i i i think it was julian
fellows the writer decided i've got some
good ideas you know with the irish
character the chauffeur and the lady of
the house yeah so yeah i'm glad that the
ideas were there yeah i mean not just
for you but for us we love you yeah
um so and now i'm the focus of the new
movie how crazy is that it's different
now right yeah i mean it was great my
character went through like a lot of
heartache and heartbreak and the movie
opens with his wedding no spoilers
because it's in the trailer but uh it's
great that my character finally finds
happiness you know which is something
that i really wanted for him and i think
he deserved yeah
agreed well it's time for a quick break
everybody downton abbey a new era is in
theaters now everybody should go see it
[Music]